jeff in dallas starts us off this hour
hi jeff welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you so much how are you doing
today better than i deserve how can
rachel not help
yes thank you uh so my wife and i have
made a lot of progress in a relatively
short amount of time
our only debt left is our house but
honestly i feel like i've done
most of it on my own she's not
necessarily pushing back on
when we were attacking debt and our
other planning but i feel like
when i bring up the conversation to move
forward she's just
not necessarily interested it's just not
her cup of tea
and you know as successful as we've been
i know it's going to be that much
better once we're on the same page and i
just would i'm looking for some advice
on how to get her on that same page
so going forward do you mean saving up
for the emergency funds
funding retirement when you say moving
forward what do you mean exactly that
she doesn't
want to be on board with retirement fund
is set
i'm sorry um emergency fund is set um
you know retirement planning our kids
college like we're
we're starting to invest but i feel like
she's just not
connecting in all the conversations that
that makes sense and um
how we can get on the same page is what
i'm really looking for
okay well i mean funding the retirement
15
of your income is she wanting to do less
than that i'm trying to understand what
her pushback is
or is it just that you guys aren't she's
not pushing back she's just not pushing
forward i think is what you're saying is
that right
a little bit of both yes um yeah i mean
she
you know not necessarily
thinking about retirement as much as i
am i mean we're young we're in our 30s
but i still feel like we got a later
start than i should have
yeah and i just want to yeah you know be
on the same page
moving forward for sure well and the
fact that you got i mean you guys got
through the hardest stuff i mean baby
step two and three
that's the exhausting time of life you
know when you're living like that so the
fact that you guys got through that
together is awesome
and just as long as you're not
continuing trying to be gazelle intense
and continuing to sacrifice as deeply as
you guys have been
because baby steps four five and six is
really really where you can let your
foot off the gas
you guys can go on save up for a
vacation you can replace a car like you
can actually start living life a little
bit more
it's just that 15 of your income going
away into retirement and then yeah sure
looking at kids college for the future
and all that but you guys are still
young you
you do have some time to just kind of
breathe so i'm just wondering from her
end because i'm probably more like her
honestly i'm more of a spender i'm more
of a free spirit
so if i was in her shoes and just say
okay yeah i am
making these sacrifices now um
at this point i would want to start to
live my life so do you feel like you
guys are having these conversations
about doing fun things again
we are um you know obviously more
post-covet and that really makes sense
we were very gazelle intense for the
better part of the year
knocked out a lot of debt and um you
know i could probably
learn to take my foot off the gas as you
said yeah i think i was gonna
say jeff let me ask let me tell you what
i think i'm hearing and you tell me if
i'm wrong
okay i think i'm hearing you are a super
intense
nerd that loves the details and you have
loved
this process of having a goal and
focusing on it and pushing through
and you're like 90 percent you know you
you got your foot on the
on the gas may be too intense maybe not
but at least you you really spend a lot
of head space dealing with this
and she's like spending 20 head space
and you're spending 90 percent
and it just feels kind of like she's a
little bit apathetic
and all it is is you're like a super
nerd did i miss something
i think you hit the nail on the head
okay because that's kind of the way it
can be sometimes at my house and i'm
freaking dave ramsey okay
so i'm the guy that thinks about this
stuff all the time because i teach it
all the time and i want to make sure
we're modeling it
we're not being hypocritical that we've
done this stuff and so i might for
instance on our estate plan
in a given year i might have 40 hours
invested and my wife might have 40
minutes
like when she attends the one meeting
that we do once a year where we cover
our estate plan with the whole family
and then we all go to dinner and she's
wondering what's for dinner
yeah okay yeah that's the truth i mean
that's a sharon ramsey story isn't it
yeah and i talk about this in my new
book know yourself know your money about
these tendencies and her tendency
probably is just more of a free spirit
and so she probably just is
just not really thinking about it that
much so and and jeff that's me
like that in my relationship my husband
is the one that plans
our investment meetings every year with
our financial advisor i mean he's the
one that
loves to get into the details and i do
this for a living and i don't as much so
like
yeah i'm probably on here she doesn't
hold on but you don't hold winston back
you don't
argue to do something dumb to offset the
process
but you're just not you're just not
spending all your focus and your energy
on it because it's just not it's not
like your favorite hobby
exactly like if i was like babe let's
just let's just run out some numbers and
look at compound interest he'd be like
what yes
and i don't so that's fine who are you
what have you done with my wife
yeah all that that's all it is jeff is
she may never really
be a super nerd like you are but as long
as you guys are talking about
things having shared vision shared goal
with where you guys want to be as a
family like you're on the same team
but one of you just me maybe like the
varsity player that's just so excited
about the game
all the time